[Music]
we just moved into number 61. are you
married
no it's just a little collective
co-investors that's right
five of us are you all related or is
this a religious thing
you know five singles ready to mingle
i'm pretty sure he thinks he's just been
invited to a sex party
yeah roger that harry
liz heather myself and ben shared one
painfully solid bond the five of us
could buy a house and you'd have more
buying power than a married couple times
two
this story is about that
did it smell like this before classic
buyer's remorse
oh there's water coming in remind me why
we're doing this again we couldn't
afford anything we liked and we wanted
pool
this could be the biggest mistake of my
life but i can't keep standing still
no matter how bad it gets you've got to
focus on the people you love
that kind of thing takes guts
it's perfect
everything okay this social experiment
it's working we will always need to be
i always thought it was a bit sniffy
five single people under one roof
you